à ce type de situation pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez choisi d'écrire sur cette
expérience c'est important après le 13
novembre j'ai entendu et élus un peu
tout et n'importe quoi une le médecin
son rôle c'est d'arriver à aborder des
sujets difficiles graves ou la mort mais
il sans cacher la vérité
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mercredi 2 février que
retenir du grand oral des candidats de
la droite organisée par le syndicat
alliance la candidate heller valérie
pécresse veut augmenter les effectifs
chez les policiers tout comme la
candidate fn marine le pen d'anciens
polémiste eric zemmour affirme lui que
la lutte contre l'immigration est la
mère de toutes les batailles alors les
candidats répondent ils vraiment aux
besoins de la police on attend vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme
d'ayrté france et on en débat
la gauche a quant à elle décliné
l'invitation du syndicat alliance jean
luc mélenchon a lui carrément pas été
conviés une gauche qui a mis le cap
aujourd'hui sur la question du mal
logement en france à fabien roussel
christiane taubira anne hidalgo et jean
luc mélenchon ont décliné aujourd'hui
leurs propositions à la fondation abbé
pierre de son côté emmanuel macron a
reconnu qu'il fallait construire
davantage de logements sociaux un
président fustigé dans le rapport
alarmant sur le mal logement publié par
la fondation abbé pierre
la crise ukrainienne suite entretient
aujourd'hui entre le président russe et
le premier ministre britannique
la lumière poutine et boris johnson qui
s'accordent sur la nécessité de trouver
une résolution pacifique de son côté
emmanuel macron n'exclut pas de se
rendre à moscou les etats-unis eux
menacent toujours et passe même à
l'action washington s'apprête à envoyer
trois mille soldats supplémentaires en
europe de l'est déclaration du pentagone
sur fond de tensions avec la russie dans
ce dossier ukrainien
au sommaire à 21h nous nous
intéresserons à la hausse des prix des
matières premières le prix du beurre par
exemple il s'est envolé de 33% sur les
trois derniers mois dans notre rubrique
en pensent les français nous irons à la
rencontre ce soir d'un boulanger son
équipe qui souffre aussi de cette
augmentation
aujourd'hui ils n'ont plus le choix pour
survivre ils envisagent d'augmenter le
prix de leur baguette est pour vous le
pouvoir d'achat est il désormais de
l'inquiétude numéro un en attend vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme daté
france
des candidats à la présidentielle ont
donc passé leur grand oral sur les
questions sécuritaires aujourd'hui
invitation lancée par le syndicat police
alliance pour entendre leurs
propositions on en parle tout de suite
avec un autre reporter lucas léger
bonsoir le cas les candidats qui se sont
donc succédés à la tribune alors que
retenir de leur allocution
déjà qu'ils ont eu mon temps pour
s'exprimer il y a eu une phase de
discours qu'une phase des changes avec
ses policiers du syndicat alliance
l'événement s'appelait les candidats
face à la réalité des flics comme vous
l'avez dit il n'y avait que les candides
raddad droite qui a qui ont répondu à
cet appel et chacun a rivalisé de
propositions pour faire respecter la
police est aussi on a parlé d'eux moyen
de proposition de loi je vous propose
d'écouter ce que valérie pécresse et
marine le pen ont dit il y aura une
grande loi pour renforcer les moyens des
policiers et puis je le dis aujourd'hui
la nation doit protéger ceux qui la
protègent voilà la situation dans
laquelle on en est dans laquelle on est
arrivé on doit protéger ce qui nous
protège avec des nouvelles lois qui
garantiront l'anonymat des policiers
pour qu'ils soient pas jetés en pâture
qui leur permettront de se défendre
efficacement lorsqu'ils sont attaqués
qui leur permettront aussi de d'exercer
leur métier en sécurité alors je le dis
quand on attaquera un policier ce sera
un an de prison ferme je ferai donc
voter une loi de programmation pour la
sécurité et la justice de 7,5 milliards
d'euros sur cinq ans qui permettra de
créer 7000 postes de policiers et
gendarmes 3000 postes de personnels
administratifs pour vous permettre
d'être davantage sur le terrain je
n'attendrai pas 2030 pour renforcer le
nombre de policiers affectés à des
missions opérationnelles
afin de rejoindre la moyenne européenne
j'engagerai le doublement du nombre de
magistrats tout en diversifiant leur
mode de recrutement en y intégrant
notamment d'anciens policiers parce
qu'il est des tâches qui ne relèvent pas
de vos interventions et par souci de
complémentarité des missions les
communes de plus de 10 mille habitants
devront se doter d'une police municipale
pour eric zemmour quant à lui c'est la
lutte contre l'immigration qui est
principales réponses à apporter à la
délinquance il a par ailleurs promis
d'expulser les mineurs isolés et la
suppression des allocations familiales
pour les parents de mineurs délinquants
et aussi l'expulsion des hlm pour ceux
qui habitent marine le pen est lui aussi
pointé du doigt les black blocks et
l'impunité dont il jouirait
et le cas côté gouvernement c'est le
ministre de l'intérieur qui s'est rendu
au chevet des forces de l'ordre
oui absolument gérald darmanin était là
pour le compte du parti et lorraine
puisque emmanuel macron ne s'est pas
encore officiellement porté candidat il
a défendu le bilan du président au cours
de son quinquennat notamment les grandes
lois sécuritaires la loi sécurité
globale où la loi contre les
séparatistes a aussi rappelé toutes les
mesures qui ont été prises pour
améliorer le quotidien des policiers je
vous propose de l'écouter je pense que
nous devons tous constater les efforts
très importants qui ont été faits
pendant ce quinquennat à la demande du
président de la république
singulièrement par le garde des sceaux
et par les mises intérieur successifs
c'est ce que j'essaie de démontrer sur
la protection des policiers leur attaque
les menaces qu'il subissait de leur
famille est indéniable évidemment on
doit le constater ça fait 15 ans qu'ils
voient une augmentation générale des
violences contre eux et l'article 24 qui
a été tant décrié que personne n'avait
soutenu à l'époque à l'exception du
président de la république aujourd'hui
et publié permet de poursuivre ceux qui
s'attaquent aux policiers la loi
séparatisme qui permet de protéger tous
les fonctionnaires et notamment les
policiers quand ils sont menacés dans
leur vie personnelle mais la fin des
remises de peine automatiques pour ceux
qui agressent un policier et lucas
grande absente en pensée doléances des
policiers les gauches
exactement il y avait des candidats qui
était invité yannick jadot anne hidalgo
fabien roussel mais ils ne sont pas
venus jean luc mélenchon lui par contre
n'a pas été invité il a une inimitié de
longue date avec le syndicat alliance
qui l'a accusé de haine anti-flic lui a
répliqué sur twitter et a déclaré que ce
n'était pas un événement syndicales mais
un meeting d'extrême droite il a déclaré
que le vrai événement du jour c'était la
remise du rapport annuel de la fondation
abbé pierre sur le mal-logement et de
fait c'était là qu'était tous les
candidats de la gauche à la fondation
abbé-pierre aujourd'hui merci de calais
j'ai pour ce compte rendu est une
déclaration d'amour aux forces de
l'ordre des politiques qui promettent de
faire de la sécurité une priorité alors
est ce que ces candidats est-ce qu'ils
répondent aux besoins de la police c'est
l'heure de notre face à face
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler sur ce plateau
pierre vitaly délégué régional des
républicains membres du bureau national
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés en direct par skype josé mendes
secrétaire section ps pays basque
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous également
je me demandais ça on vient d'en parler
à la gauche grande absente de ce grand
oral est ce que ce n'est pas un mauvais
signal que les socialistes envoient ou
aux français pour qui la sécurité fait
tout de même partie des grands enjeux de
la présidentielle
effectivement tous les candidats de
gauche ou en tout cas ceux qui ont été
invités ont compris que les conditions
de dérouler d'un débat serein n'étaient
pas réunies on effectivement partie d'un
film de grande qualité au demeurant mais
d'une fiction pour parler d'un sujet
tout aussi importante je pense
réellement qu'il aurait été nécessaire
de faire un grand oral sans qu'il y ait
de films et aussi pourquoi pas un grand
oral avec différents syndicats pas
seulement le syndicat alliance plusieurs
syndicats pour un débat est un débat qui
puisse représenter les différents
courants de pensée qui existe dans la
police mais ce qui ne veut pas dire que
nous nous désintéressons pas de ces
questions qui sont pour les socialistes
importante et sur ces questions nous
avons bien sûr des propositions et un
bilan tout à fait crédible à défendre
sur ce sujet bien vite a dit justement
sur ce choix de ce syndicat alliance est
vrai qui a finalement été à l'initiative
de cette affiche très diffusés sur les
médias mélenchon 10 ans n'était pas un
congrès en plein meeting d'extrême
droite en gros par même des partis
d'extrême droite at il répondu il a
effectivement préféré tout comme les
candidats de gauche par les logements
qu'est ce que vous répondez ça manque
vraiment une fracture entre la gauche et
la droite aujourd'hui dans ce qu'elle
est par essence oui écouter sur
surprenant avec la gauche il aime le
débat que lorsque c'est avec des
personnes qui sont d'accord avec elle là
pour le coup on avait un syndicat y
avait pas que ce syndicat d'ailleurs je
pense seniors il y avait d'autres
présentant d'autres syndicats même si tu
es alliance police qui organisait le
film
bac nord on n'était pas obligé de
regarder ainsi si les candidats de
gauche voulaient pas le voir il sait pas
obligé de venir on avait eu des
candidats qu'ils n'aient s'exprimer sur
une question qui est extrêmement
importante et si la gauche aujourd'hui
n'est pas capable de répondre à ces
questions liées à la sécurité plus
globalement on comprend pourquoi les
bazin et son âge c'est une préoccupation
la droite ne doit pas avoir le monopole
de la sécurité c'est toutes les forces
politiques qui devraient se battre pour
remettre de l'ordre dans notre pays josé
mendes est vrai que sur cette diffusion
du film back nord il ya eu plusieurs
critiques notamment chez vous à gauche
on rappelle un petit peu voilà l'idée du
film même si je vais le résumé
certainement de manière un peu trop
lapidaire ici des policiers qui se
sentent
abandonnés finalement par les politiques
par les pouvoirs publics est ce que pour
vous c'est un bon diagnostic ça
correspond aujourd'hui à la réalité dans
notre pays du traitement des policiers
oui tout à fait effectivement c'est un
film que j'ai vu et que j'ai beaucoup
apprécié mais je m'étonne dans tant de
monsieur vital et dire que la gauche
n'est pas capable et n'aime pas le débat
nous avons prouvé nous que nous étions
capables d'aider les policiers je
rappelle que le gouvernement dans le
haut qu'elles participent et madame
pécresse entre 2007 et 2012 a supprimé
près de 13000 postes de fonctionnaires
de police et de gendarmerie donc ça
c'est le bilan de la droite cette bilan
de madame pécresse qui aujourd'hui nous
dit qu'elle veut ressortir le kärcher et
de reprendre les méthodes de nicolas
sarkozy mais vous avez bien vu vous avez
supprimer plusieurs milliers de postes
de fonctionnaires baissé les dépenses
d'investissement notamment pour leur
permettre d'avoir des équipements
correct donc vous avez une lourde
responsabilité la droite dans cette
situation vous devriez d'ailleurs vous
excusez nous aujourd'hui nous avons des
propositions et un bilan crédible je
rappelle que sous la présidence de
françois hollande nous avons essayé de
rattraper le retard le lourd bilan le
lourd boulet de la droite puisque nous
avons recruté près de 9000 postes de
fonctionnaires de policiers et de
gendarmes donc nous avons un bilan qui
tout à fait positif et nous n'avons
aucune leçon à recevoir de la droite je
tenais à dire ce soir le diagnostic il
est posé les policiers et les gendarmes
sont dans des situations difficiles il
faut les écouter les accompagner c'est
pour ça que nous proposons d'augmenter
aussi le nombre de postes de
fonctionnaires comme nous l'avons déjà
fait les aussi d'augmenter parce qu'elle
baisse ces dernières et les dépenses
d'équipement parce qu'aujourd'hui ce
n'est plus possible nous le comprenons
d'exercer dans des conditions qui sont
difficiles qu'est ce que vous répondez
tout d'abord à cette critique qui
revient souvent quand on
revient souvent mais c'était il ya plus
de dix ans que la droite était aux
responsabilités moi j'étais en cinquième
donc je veux bien qu'on nous reproche
beaucoup de choses mais
en revanche à quelque chose de plus
intéressant c'est à dire que la droite
est aux responsabilités comme je dis ya
plus de dix ans aujourd'hui elle est aux
responsabilités dans les régions et par
exemple valérie pécresse elle un bilan
qui est beaucoup plus proche qui est
celui dans sa région ile de france où
elle a fait un bouclier sécurité dans
lequel par exemple à donner la gratuité
des transports pour les policiers afin
qu'ils puissent performer leur travail
et ça par exemple la gauche ne le fait
ne l'a pas fait à rennes est la mère de
rennes qui dans votre formation
politique l'a refusée on sait
aujourd'hui que la gauche par exemple à
nantes manifeste avec ceux qui crient à
mort la police à mort l'état alors les
bourgeois donc le bilan actuel en tout
cas pas celui qu'on nous rappelle et
qu'on aura d'autres depuis des années le
bilan actuel qui est en train de se
passer il est clair valérie pécresse
elle agit au niveau de sa région et les
les franciliens le vois bien ça c'est
certain d'ailleurs on va voir les
propositions de valérie pécresse
finalement le rattraper la droite passé
puisqu'elle veut recruter aujourd'hui
7000 policiers et gendarmes ont augmenté
le budget de la sécurité de la police
envoyer l'armée dans les quartiers
difficiles soir à en parler après mais
tout d'abord justement sur ses effectifs
huit mille policiers a recruté
dernièrement augmentation de la masse
salariale de 21 % en dix ans finalement
josé mendes cette augmentation des
effectifs elle n'a pas conduit
nécessairement à plus d'efficacité est
ce que c'est bien là le problème est ce
que c'est la bonne solution finalement
d'augmenter est-ce qu'il faut pas une
réforme de fond plus tôt alors il ya
deux éléments il ya effectivement
l'augmentation du nombre de
fonctionnaires qui me semble aujourd'hui
essentielle nous ne proposons pas des
chiffres qui seraient sortis du chapeau
qui seraient des chiffres qui ne
s'appliquerait pas sur une réalité vous
proposons une fois élu de créer un
diagnostic local de sécurité et en
fonction des territoires est bien de
proposer un nombre de 2 d'augmentation
du nombre de fonctionnaires mais il faut
que ça marche sur deux pieds et le
deuxième pied à mon sens je disais tout
à l'heure c'est l'augmentation des
dépenses pour les équipements jeu je
disais que aujourd'hui lors que l'on
recrute 3 fonctionnaires et bien on
supprime une voiture de police parce que
les dépenses d'équipement diminue depuis
nombreuses années même si lorsque nous
étions responsabilités nous avons
augmenté donc il faut aujourd'hui que
les policiers et des équipements
nécessaires pour pouvoir agir au
quotidien au service des français et
l'autre point qui me semble essentiel
c'est la formation la formation des
policiers elle est essentielle
aujourd'hui elle passe à 12 mois je
pense que c'est une bonne chose il faut
former les policiers pour qu'ils
puissent être tout à fait fort mais être
bien physiquement être bien
techniquement mais aussi juridiquement
pour leur action et je pense qu'il faut
poursuivre ce travail et c'est ce que
nous proposons d'investir aussi dans la
formation des policiers pour qu'ils
aient une formation de qualité alors
bien vite elle il ya également cette
composition de votre candidate envoyé
l'armée dans les quartiers difficiles
vous aller chasser sur le terrain de la
droite dure non on va pas chasser sur le
terrain la droite dure on essaie de
répondre à une problématique qui est
réel et il faut arrêter je pense avec le
se fait de dire que dès qu'on propose
des mesures pour rétablir l'ordre on
nous accuse de l'extrême droite à force
de dire ça on a aujourd'hui sur notre
droite des partis qui a qui arrivent à
des scores dans les sondages aidant les
yankees sont énormes il faut répondre à
ses attentes on parle pas d'envoyer
l'armée pour pour régler non plus tous
les problèmes on explique
jusqu'aujourd'hui il ya déjà l'armée
dans avec l'opération sentinelle etc qui
sont dans les villes et il faut savoir
les utiliser pour venir supplée t la
police aidée la police je suis d'accord
sur l'idée d'investir dans l'équipement
avec propose 5 milliards d'euros pour
investir dans l'équipement l'automobile
mais aussi dans des nouvelles techniques
numériques dans des nouvelles techniques
dans plein d'outils qui sont extrêmement
importants aujourd'hui
voilà valérie pécresse a aujourd'hui un
programme solide et capable de rétablir
l'ordre mais pas que sur les questions
sécuritaires de police justement un
projet présidentiel c'est un projet qui
est globale on parle aussi de redonner
la puissance à la justice on parle aussi
de réduire l'immigration on parle aussi
de d'apaiser la société de redonner des
moyens à l'école c'est vrai que c'est de
redonner les moyens de la famille est
revenue partout un an dans tout la
bouche des candidats aujourd'hui il ya
eu ce lien
entre délinquance et immigration s'avoue
l'assumé
complètement l'a toujours assumé à
droite je suis pas sûr que la gauche il
assume aujourd'hui mais en tout cas nous
on l'assumé on essaye d'y apporter des
réponses on a connu valérie pécresse un
peu plus aux rondeurs sur ce type de
sujet à une époque tout de même jeunes
ont enfin elle a quitté le parti pour la
ligne droite hier que voulait lui
imposer l'ordre ont évoqué par exemple
ce n'est pas que sur la ligne droitière
aujourd'hui fin il faut il faut regarder
les programmes faut regarder l'action et
pas sur les la communication les petites
phrases qu'on peut qu'on peut penser
aujourd'hui c'est patrick stefanini qui
l'a aidé à faire son programme sur la
sécurité on a aujourd'hui des talents à
droite qui l'aideront à appliquer un
programme de droite assumé il faut pas
avoir peur là dessus un non on est un
parti de responsabilité avec des
personnes sérieuses qui sont cas qui
seront capables de faire concrètement je
pense à quelqu'un comme comme monsieur
péchenard comme monsieur ciotti comme
sur otayo on a des talents qui sont là
et qui seront là pour appliquer et pas
voilà ces polémiques dans lequel on
essaie de nous de nous de nous placer
quoi je revendais ça nous inspire quoi
qu'on vous entendez ça monsieur
péchenard un proche d'ailleurs de de
nicolas sarkozy qui travaille
aujourd'hui au côté de valérie pécresse
il ne faut pas avoir la main qui tremble
en matière de sécurité c'est une vraie
demande de la part des français à
laquelle la gauche doit également
répondre
doit répondre elle a déjà prouvé je ne
vais pas me répéter mais lorsque nous
avons été aux responsabilités notamment
bernard cazeneuve à être ingrat ministre
de l'intérieur mais je vous confirme que
nous ne chassons pas nous sur les terres
de l'extrême droite de monsieur de
monsieur zemmour de madame le pen ce qui
est le cas je le regrette des
républicains notamment au travers de
monsieur ciotti il faut être ferme sur
ces questions régalienne de police et je
partage aussi ce qui a été dit même si
les désaccords sont nombreux il faut
tenir un discours ferme mais la police
ne va pas sans la justice j'ai entendu
ce matin une mise en cause de la justice
qui est intolérable la justice et la
police doivent travailler main dans la
main pour être au service des français
et aussi nous proposons d'augmenter
sensiblement le budget de la justice
pour que et elle a lancé un appel le 3
min magistrats greffiers il faut
entendre cet appel au service des
français encore une fois jean en tout
cas marine le pen elle aussi évidemment
appris la parole on va voir à l'antenne
d'ailleurs s'afficher
qu'alléger nous on faisait un résumé
tout à l'heure les propositions phares
de marine le pen qui mise aussi sur le
recrutement des policiers augmenter
leurs salaires alors c'est vrai que
marine le pen elle concentrerait 60% des
votes des policiers en tout cas c'est
une étude c'est ce qui ressort d'une
enquête électorale du cevipof c'est vrai
que cette enquête elle date de mai 2021
ça veut dire qu'il n'y avait pas encore
eric zemmour y avait pas votre candidate
valérie pécresse aujourd'hui vous pensez
que vous pourrez rattraper cette
tendance se tournant des policiers qui
se sont rapprochés du rassemblement
national je suis certain évidemment
qu'il ya une colère dans la police qui
montent parce que dessous gouvernement
macron son gouvernement même de monsieur
hollande j'ai l'impression que c'était
la belle époque mais je pense que les
français savent que nous on n'avait pas
un soutien à la police ils savent que la
droite française les soutient et plus
que les soutenir ils la droite française
est capable d'agir pour eux et voilà il
ya le problème de la police on propose
des moyens pas que des moyens d'ailleurs
il faut aussi réorganisation une
réorganisation en interne arrêtez avec
une forme d'administration de deux
masters c'est pas que sur les questions
de la police peu après les crises
propose un comité de la hache pour
justement des normes et toute cette
paperasse et bureaucratie qui nous
étouffe et qui finalement concentrent
des fonctionnaires à des postes
administratifs de bureaux au lieu d'être
sur le terrain et donc donc ya pas non
plus qu'une question de moyens et en
plus les je suis certain que les
policiers seront à nos côtés parce que
la droite française a toujours été à
leurs côtés voilà je n'ai pas souvenir
que la gauche est toujours été là dans
les manifs ou où souvent on mélange un
petit peu tout violences policières etc
nous on sait que la police est là pour
rétablir l'ordre elle a pas un métier
facile un jeu
je pense qu on est tous conscients
aujourd'hui que cette place d'aller
parfois dans des quartiers sensibles on
est on est pas bien accueillis de faire
un travail et où la justice parfois
casse ce travail mais ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui est facile et je peux
comprendre une colère de la part des
policiers mais à cette colère doit
maintenant s'appuyer sur comment
concrétiser l'action politique et pour
concrétiser l'action politique un parti
de gouvernement font un parti sérieux et
il ya que valérie pécresse qui proposent
ces jouets mendes bien vite elle y vient
de prononcer de mots de violences
policières c'est vrai que c'est une
notion qui est qu on a souvent entendu
un notamment sur le quinquennat macron
avec cet épisode d'aidé gilet jaune
s'est entraîné une forme de désamour
d'une partie en tout cas de la
population et de la classe politique
envers les policiers comment vous vous
situez justement la gauche il faut
rappeler que c'est quand les policy les
policiers et gendarmes font un métier
extrêmement difficile
mais il exerce avant tout avant toute
chose une mission de service public
cette mission de service public elle
doit se faire dans le respect du droit
et de la déontologie qui sait s'applique
aux policiers il ne faut avoir aucun
atermoiements lorsque certains et c'est
une minorité ont des comportements qui
dévie et il faut le souligner les
sanctionner moi je n'ai pas de problème
avec le terme la langue française il ya
des violences qui sont commises par une
minorité de policiers je n'ai aucun
problème à avoir à les qualifier de
violences policières nous proposons
d'ailleurs de créer une autorité
administrative indépendante qui aura
pour charge d'examiner non pas dans une
phase judiciariser mais une phrase phase
préalable toutes ces questions de
comportement qui ne serait pas conforme
au droit elle a d anthologie en tout cas
je me dis nous avons un soutien réel des
forces de police contrairement à ce que
ce monsieur a dit monsieur vitaly nous
les avons soutenus lorsque nous étions
responsabilité nous les soutenons dans
le cadre de notre programme et entre lui
entre la droite et la gauche je dirais
que c'est pas nous qui avons je le
répète mais c'est quand même important
parce que pour savoir où l'on va il faut
savoir d'où l'on vient et lorsque l'on a
supprimé
13 et les postes de fonctionnaires eh
bien ça il faut pas que les policiers
l'oubli c'est le gouvernement de
monsieur fillon avec nicolas sarkozy et
valérie pécresse donc ça il ne faut pas
l'oublier on va consacrer la toute
dernière partie puisqu'il reste plus
beaucoup de temps à auby dans des
ménages macro 1 puisque mais ne le
mettront toujours pas candidat
évidemment on le sait être représentée
par son ministre de l'intérieur dont le
propos a finalement consisté à la
défense du bilan du chef de l'état
justement je vous propose de regarder
ces chiffres en quelques-uns bilan
sécuritaire sur cinq ans les homicides +
12 % coups et blessures + 31% alors on
va être totalement honnête et dire que
les cambriolages ont également baissé
baisse également de 31 % des vols
violents sans arme ce qu'un bilan en
demi-teinte pierre vitaly pan vous vous
vous dites que les les cambriolages ont
baissé en perte de confinement encore
heureux je pense que les couvrir la gbc
donc voilà il n'ya pas le bilan et reste
très mauvais il est mauvais et en même
temps c'est normal parce qu'on veut pas
faire justement du en même temps sur les
questions sécuritaires on peut pas avoir
un ministre de l'intérieur qui dit à
élise de la justice qui dit b il faut
une cohérence politique
cette cohérence politique la droite la
porte tous les jours il ya 765 agression
tous les jours il ya 100 personnes
dépositaires de l'ordre public qui sont
contestés qui sont menacés et donc
finalement le programme de la droite
aujourd'hui c'est de ramener de l'ordre
mais de l'ordre à tous niveaux de
l'ordre de la justice dans la police
comme je les dis mais c'est finalement
ramené une forme de deux mentalités un
respect oui on doit le respect aux
policiers oui on doit le respect aux
pompiers parce que les pompiers sont
agressés oui on doit le respect aux
professeurs et tout ça c'est le rêve
d'une société qui est sereine voilà je
suis pas quelqu'un qui est sécuritaire
absolument je veux juste une société qui
soit apaisée qui soit sereine jusqu'à ma
génération on n'aie pas peur de rentrer
chez nous tard le soir je veux juste que
les films ma génération et puisse aller
en boîte sans réfléchir à comment elles
vont rentrer etc c2c des problèmes qui
touchent notre génération et aujourd'hui
voilà je suis désolé mais non la gauche
ne ne soutient pas la police
lorsqu'olivier fort s'est déplacé à la
manifestation de soutien la police ça a
fait du remue au sein du parti
socialiste au sein de la gauche parce
que on aurait peur d'être justement
qualifié d'extrême droite ou de je ne
sais quoi non soutient la police n'est
pas être extrême droite c'est juste un
bon sens et je pense que si aujourd'hui
la gauche et à des scores si faible
c'est justement parce qu'elle refuse de
voir la réalité la réalité du monde elle
n'est pas forcément
joyeuse et une partie de l'électorat qui
voter à gauche aujourd'hui sont sans
doute déçus que la gauche ne prennent
pas en considération ces questions de
sécurité et bien qu'ils soient rassurés
la droite n en a pris en conscience je
vais mendes le mot de la fin est la
réponse rapidement s'il vous plaît la
réponse rapide c'est que je remercie
monsieur vitaly de faire l'exégèse de la
pensée socialiste n'était absolument pas
le cas nous avons dans notre programme
un programme qui éclaire une république
qui assurent qu'ils assument la justice
l'état de droit et la sécurité pour les
français c'est dans le programme d'anne
hidalgo et nous avons aucune espèce aux
dates et un moment sur cette question je
vous remercie tous les deux joué mendes
qui a ravitaillé d'avoir été avec nous
pour ce décryptage et un grand écart à
grand écart thématique au coeur de la
campagne donc pendant que les candidats
de la droite était à ce grand oral de la
police et bien c'est la question
brûlante du mal logement qui a régné
aujourd'hui la gauche les candidats qui
se sont rendus à la présentation du
rapport de la fondation abbé-pierre une
enquête qui dresse un constat alarmant
sur l'état du mal-logement en france les
détails avec toi ni pitaro
un quinquennat jugé sévèrement selon le
rapport rendu ce mercredi par la
fondation abbé pierre la présidence d'
emmanuel macron n'a pas été à la hauteur
des enjeux sociaux qui entoure la
question du logement des chiffres
accablants souligné par la fondation
plus de 4 millions de personnes
souffrent de mal-logement tandis que
plus de deux millions huit cent mille
personnes vivraient dans des conditions
précaires on compte également trois cent
mille sans domicile fixe il faut aussi
noter la réforme des apl une baisse de 5
euros qui a suscité un véritable tollé
en 2018 face à cette situation les
candidats de la gauche à l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22 se sont
succédé sur la scène de la fondation
abbé pierre tous ont proposé des
solutions à l'image d'anne hidalgo qui
veut avant tout construire il faut
construire je suis du côté des maires
bâtisseurs et il faut produire du
logement jean luc mélenchon de son côté
s'intéresse aux logements vacants qu'il
veut réquisitionnés pour lancer une
véritable mot utilisation nationale sous
l'étendard du zéro sdf il ya trois
millions de logements vacants dans ce
pays bons premiers chiffres deuxième
chiffre à bay hill et là c'est 3,5 pour
cent de personnes possèdent
la moitié des logements à mettre en
location alors quel rapport y entre eux
les 3 millions vide et cela c'est pour
ça qu'on est ce que c'est à eux parce
que si c'est à eux j'ai encore moins de
réticences à dire je vais réquisitionnés
christiane taubira elle demande d'un
état stratège sur la question mais reste
flou sur les moyens le candidat
écologiste yannick jadot de son côté
propose de renforcer la loi solidarité
renouvellement urbain c'est 10 milliards
d'euros d'investissements par an sur
la rénovation thermique des logements
des propositions pour tenter d'enrayer
une crise du logement que la pandémie a
considérablement accéléré mais comme à
chaque campagne présidentielle si le mal
logement revient au goût du jour reste à
savoir si ces propositions survivront à
leur candidat et le nombre de personnes
sans domicile fixe et a doublé en dix
ans la fondation abbé-pierre points dont
du doigt emmanuel macron le président
reconnaît ne pas être allé assez loin
mais défend son bilan sur le logement
social alors le gouvernement actuel en
partie responsable du mal logement la
réponse avec liam un rossi
14,8 millions de personnes fragilisées
par la crise du logement plus de 4
millions de personnes non aux mal-logés
300000 personnes aujourd'hui sans
domicile un nombre qui a doublé en une
décennie et triplé depuis 2001 depuis
décembre 2021 près de 4000 personnes ont
tenté chaque soir en vain de joindre le
115 faute de places d'hébergement
disponibles à la mi novembre rien qu'en
seine-saint-denis 60 enfants de moins de
3 ans et à la rue n'ont pas pu être mise
à l'abri pourtant il y a cinq ans elle
était ambitieuse la promesse faite aux
mal logés la première bataille
c'est de loger tout le monde dignement
je ne veux plus d'ici la fin de l'année
à voir des femmes et des hommes
dans les rues c'est une question de
dignité c'est une question d'humanité et
d'efficacité là aussi alors il faut
préciser que le président de la
république parle est ici de la situation
plus spécifique des sans abri demandeurs
d'asile une promesse ciblées qui n'a de
toute façon pas été suivies de mesures
suffisantes plus largement les moyens
déployés pour lutter contre le mal
logement au cours de ce quinquennat
n'ont clairement pas été à la hauteur
des enjeux depuis 1984 l'effort public
pour le logement n'a jamais été aussi
faible les aides au logement sont en
effet passés de 1,82 pour cent du pib en
2010 est à 1 63 % en 2020 la production
annuelle de logements sociaux n'a
quasiment fait que baisser ces dernières
années et l'offre a progressé deux fois
moins vite que la demande et c'est sans
compter les coupes dans les aides
financières à destination des plus
précaires comme la baisse des apl par
exemple la part du budget de l'état
consacré au logement est passé de 42
milliards d'euros en 2010 est à 38
milliards en 2020 15 milliards d'euros
d'économies ont été réalisées sur ce
quinquennat alors que les recettes
fiscales ont augmenté
tout ceci en cohérence avec un axiome
maintenant bien connu
et on tuera tiff
d'impôts
alors évidemment cette période de
campagne les voeux pieux reviennent à la
mode et certains candidats à la fonction
suprême ont fait des propositions comme
jean luc mélenchon avec son plan
mal-logement 0 sans abri d'ici cinq ans
une promesse qui rappelle celle d'
emmanuel macron en 2017 de nicolas
sarkozy en 2006 ou même de lionel jospin
en 2002 quant aux premiers appels de
l'abbé pierre en faveur des sans abri et
des mal logés
c'était le 1er février 1954 il y à 58
ans
et pour en parler nous sommes avec eux
alexis poulin et d'auto réaliste rt
fonce
soir alexis café vous retenir de qu'avez
vous retenu de ce grand oral sur le
logement des candidats à la
présidentielle aujourd'hui
alors c'est vrai que le logement c'est
enfin un thème dont on parle jusqu'à
présent ils étaient oubliés de la
campagne et pourtant c'est le poste de
dépenses le plus important les chiffres
qui font froid dans le dos 300000 sdf
qui aimons les chiffres comme plus que
doublé en deux ans les 4 millions de mal
logés de la fondation abbé pierre et on
a eu à la suite tous les candidats
majoritairement de gauche qui sont venus
expliciter leur mesure
alors tous sont à revoir les minima
sociaux à taxer les plus riches avec lui
et c'est peut-être le retour de vie et 7
à voir un grand plan de bâti construire
de nouveaux logements et donc il y avait
une candidate en revanche qui a été
extrêmement floue plutôt mal préparés
certains ont même parlé de naufrage
s'était christiane taubira qui avait
bien du mal à répondre de mesures
qu'elle avait expliqué sur un coin de
table sans chiffre finalement sans
vraiment savoir et puis ce plan zéro sdf
en cinq ans de jean luc mélenchon qui
rappelle les promesses un bien sûr
qu'ils sont fait à chaque fois en début
de quinquennat c'était le cas pour
nicolas sarkozy pourrait mener le
maquereau là ils essayent de s'appuyer
justement sur le rapport de la fondation
abbé pierre mais on voit que malgré les
nombreuses mesures il y a beaucoup de
travail à faire compte tenu de du bilan
calamiteux des bleus le maquereau en
matière de logement social justement
bilan calamiteux c'est à dire parce qu
on vous l'avait dit il ya vécu quand
même pas mal de promesses et il y est
mort aussi nous l'a rappelé oui alors
dans le rapport de la fondation abbé
pierre il est écrit que c'est un parent
pauvre du quinquennat il ya eu des
coupes budgétaires inédites voire des
attaques contre le logement social et
rien n'a été fait pour encadrer la
hausse des loyers et l'explosion du prix
du logement emmanuel macron a fait du
emmanuel macron c'est à dire une
politique qui a accentué les inégalités
qui a profité aux plus riches mais qui
n'a pas permis d'aller chercher des
solutions pour le logement c'est 15
milliards par exemple d'euros qui ont
été ôtés aux plus modestes avec la
suppression de l'appel ont leur entre
autres et puis entre 2018 et 2022 l'état
a pris aux organismes hlm environ 6
milliards d'euros pour faire des
économies ces deux cent mille logements
qui n'ont pas pu être construits
finalement depuis 1984 il n'y avait
jamais eu une politique aussi peu
orienté vers le logement que celles des
malades macron donc là encore quand on
parle du bilan d' emmanuel macron bien
il faut voir combien ce bilan est
calamiteux dans de nombreux domaines et
dans le logement particulièrement on
voit à l'oeuvre cette politique d du
creusement des inégalités qu'il a mis en
place depuis son élection et puis alexis
on en parlait 1 pendant que la gauche
par les logements la droite elle faisait
son grand oral devant le syndicat
alliance
oui alors c'était deux salles deux
ambiances sein d'un côté vous aviez les
candidats plutôt de de gauche qui
parlait logement et de l'autre côté les
candidats de droite qui parlait sécurité
et police avec les syndicats policiers
de grands oraux très différents on a
l'impression qu'on avait affaire à des
camps politiques qui se raccrocher à
leurs totems d'un côté le social et de
l'autre la sécurité reste à voir ce
qu'il en ressortira je trouve ça dommage
ça aurait été bien d'avoir les candidats
de toutes les couleurs politiques pour
parler de ces deux sujets même s'il y
avait des représentants un des candidats
de chaque côté et et c'est vrai que la
sécurité c'est un thème important y
compris pour les candidats de gauche qui
ont souvent du mal à se positionner par
rapport à ça ou a même expliqué qu'elle
pourrait être leur politique et pour le
logement et bien c'est ce qu'on a vu
avec le bilan des mails macron il y
avait là un problème mais on va voir de
toute façon ces oraux se multiplier sur
des thèmes différents en fonction de
l'agenda bien sûr de la campagne
présidentielle et puis on attend enfin
qu emmanuel macron soit candidat et
peut-être prendra-t-il part aux débats
même si le porte-parole gabriel at elle
a dit que ça n'avait aucun intérêt ce
serait quand même bien de voir le
président de défendre son bilan avant de
se représenter devant les français
puisque un dernier sondage vient de
sortir et ses 57 % des français qui
pensent que l'élection des mails macron
en 2017 a été une mauvaise chose pour le
pays donc il va falloir s'expliquer
merci beaucoup et lexie pour
l'éditorialiste rt france
ils m ont justement en déplacement ce
soir dans le nord de la france pour
parler immigration un thème dont nous
parlerons d'ailleurs dans quelques
minutes avec notre expert claude
blanchemaison mais le président en a
profité
pour évoquer la crise en ukraine
annonçant un entretien avec son
homologue américain joe biden dans les
prochaines heures le chef de l'état qui
n'exclut par de se rendre à moscou
bientôt en attendant vladimir poutine
s'est lui entretenu avec boris johnson
on retrouve à notre correspondant
antoine claireaux depuis moscou très bon
soir antoine alors que retenir de cet
échange téléphonique aujourd'hui
oui % stéphanie initialement prévue
lundi puis repoussée à mardi la
conversation entre boris johnson et
vladimir poutine a finalement eu lieu ce
mercredi en fin de journée les deux
dirigeants ont ainsi échangé leurs
points de vue sur cette crise de
chrétiennes et les propositions russes
de garanties de sécurité à savoir en
priorité l'arrêt de l'extension de
l'alliance atlantique vers l'est en
particulier en ukraine les demandes
auxquelles l'otan n'a pas répondu de
façon satisfaisante d'après le président
russe celui ci a également attiré
l'attention du premier ministre
britannique sur les manquements répétés
de kiev dans l'application des accords
de minsk vous savez ce texte qui donne
une feuille de route pour régler le
conflit dans le donbass j'en propose de
regarder un extrait du communiqué du
kremlin
le président russe a exprimé ses
positions de principe sur ce sujet une
attention particulière a été portée aux
sabotages continuent par kiev des
accords de minsk il a été noté que
l'otan n'était pas prête à répondre de
manière adéquate aux préoccupations
raisonnable de la russie et se cachent
derrière la prétendue politique des
portes ouvertes de l'alliance cette
politique contredit le principe
fondamental de l'indivisibilité de la
sécurité
côté britannique déclaration a minima le
10 downing street a fait savoir que
londres et moscou s'accordent sur la
nécessité d'un règlement pacifique du
conflit il faut dire que le royaume uni
est membre de l'alliance atlantique un
participer activement à l'escaladé
tensions ces dernières semaines la
secrétaire d'état britannique a par
exemple promis des sanctions exemplaires
pour de nombreux hauts responsables
russes en cas d' escalade militaire
boris johnson qui était en déplacement à
kiev ce mardi assuré les autorités
ukrainiennes du plein soutien de son
pays a également annoncé une aide
financière supplémentaire de 88 millions
de livres sterling soit un peu plus de
105 millions d'euros il avait quelques
jours auparavant déclaré envisager un
déploiement majeur de forces
britanniques avions et navires de combat
compris en europe de l'est pour
renforcer la présence de l'otan dans la
région et ce afin de contrer je cite
l'hostilité de la russie
merci antoine claireaux en direct de
moscou et de leur côté les etats-unis
maintiennent la pression et prévoit ce
soir d'envoyer 3000 militaires
supplémentaires en renfort en europe de
l'est des soldats déployés dans les
prochains jours en soutien en force de
l'otan on retrouve thomas bonnet en
direct de washington au soir thomas
annoncé en fin de semaine dernière ce
déploiement de soldats américains
étaient confirmées par le porte parole
du pentagone aujourd'hui
absolument information officialisée tout
à l'heure par le pentagone 3000 soldats
américains qui vont donc être déployé en
europe de l'est 3000 soldats en plus des
8500 déjà placées en état d' alerte et
prêts eux aussi à être déployé en cas
d'activation d'une action conjointe de
l'otan alors ses 3000 soldats américains
vont être déployés ces prochains jours
un majoritairement en pologne mais aussi
en allemagne et en roumanie et dans le
détail mille soldats américains
actuellement en poste en allemagne vont
être renvoyés en roumanie d'ailleurs le
porte parole du pentagone a salué le
fait que la france allait également
envoyé des troupes en roumanie et puis
2000 autre soldat américain veut faire
le déplacement depuis les états unis à
destination notamment donc de
l'allemagne et de la pologne le
pentagone souligne qu'il s'agit de
mouvements qui sont temporaires et que
ces soldats n'ont pas pour but de
combattre en ukraine mais de renforcer
la sécurité des alliés de l'otan alors
la question a été posée au porte parole
du pentagone pourquoi un tel déploiement
maintenant et bien selon lui il s'agit
d'un message fort adressé à vladimir
poutine
mais aussi au reste du monde pour
expliquer que l'otan compte pour les
états unis écoutez le ici
ce que nous voyons ce sont des preuves
chaque jour qu'ils continuent de
déstabiliser la région en ajoutant de
nouvelles forces dans la partie ouest de
son pays et tout au long de la
biélorussie en plus d'activités navale
dans la méditerranée et la mer north
atlantic il est clairement en train de
se doter de plusieurs options de
capacité pour quelle raison nous ne le
savons pas encore et c'est parce que
nous ignorons ses intentions que nous
voulons être sûr d'être prêt à défendre
nos alliés sur le front de l'otan
un déploiement militaire américain
vivement critiqué du côté de moscou lé
vice ministre russe des affaires
étrangères alexandre grouchko fustige ce
mercredi une mesure je cite injustifiée
destructrice augmentant les tensions
militaires et réduisant dit il
le champ pour les décisions politiques
merci thomas bonnet en direct de
washington et pour en parler nous sommes
avec eugène berg ancien diplomate
français bonsoir jeunes berg merci
d'être avec nous les étés unis qui
annonce donc l'envoi confirme l'envoi de
3000 soldats américains supplémentaires
que peut-on déduire de cette annonce
selon vous
on peut déduire que l'agitation
militaro-diplomatique ne diminue pas et
c'est quand même dommage toute personne
sensée devrait quand même se rendre
compte que pourquoi ou fait ce
déployement
pourquoi on fait monter démonter les
enjeux et on ne rentre pas de plain pied
dans une négociation sérieuse
qui portera sur tous les volets de part
et d'autre et malheureusement c'est pas
le cas donc on a beaucoup de réunions
tout le monde beaucoup de gens vont à
kiev ce sera le cas de
du président rire de gand le président
turc
on parle également de
2,2 voyage éventuelle à moscou donc il
ya une agitation qui est un petit peu
qui accroît la tension psychologique
tout autour d'une eux c'est à dire
vraiment une discussion sur tous les
volets élargissement de l'otan
manoeuvres militaires non déplacement
non dépouillement dame offensive et
ainsi de suite c'est ça le coeur des
préoccupations
malheureusement il ya une chaire
enchères il ya les annonces alors
puisque vous parlez de boris johnson
s'est presque ironique
c'est finalement washington qu'il a
rappelés à l'ordre en disant écoutez
vous avez des oligarques il ya un argent
supposé pas tout à fait propre arrêté
finalement d'accueillir et frappé les
amis de monsieur poutine au portefeuille
c'est comme intéressant de voir que
c'est washington qui rappelle à l'ordre
son plus proche allié ça venait pas
naturellement de londres donc voilà une
explique une difficulté en plus en cas
effectivement 2 le conflit fort peu
probable
mais pourquoi annoncer des sanctions
s'ils nous même si nous même si les
anglais eux mêmes ne sont pas prêts les
supporter pour l'heure pas donc voila un
petit peu une image malheureusement
contraste est là il ya un viktor orban
que qui est montrée à l'écran qui est
très à moscou donc c'est quelqu'un qui
maintient un dialogue il est critique et
évidemment par une partie mais ça montre
que finalement le dialogue se
complexifie et heureusement qu'il existe
il ya différents points de vue et il
faut espérer dans les jours à venir où
les semaines il y aura un
éclaircissement parce qu'effectivement
ça peut pas durer aussi longtemps et ce
serait vraiment en tout cas on entend le
premier ministre britannique boris
johnson a toujours prompte à montrer ses
muscles et un petit peu rade aussi
semble-t-il elles ont donc parlé
ensemble avec vladimir poutine
aujourd'hui se sont accordés sur la
nécessité de trouver une résolution
pacifique à cette crise emmanuel macron
lui va parler à joe biden est dit
aujourd'hui n'exclut pas d'aller en
russie ça veut dire que ça va peut-être
passer par l'europe cette résolution
finalement
ça va pas passer par l'europe mais
l'europe qui était absent dès le départ
s'introduit dans le débat et c'est bien
parce que finalement c'est elle qui est
concerné c'est quand même les pays
européens et roumanie pologne sur
lesquels il ya un déploiement militaire
américain
et vous faites allusion ou quelques
milliers de soldats enfin c'est pas là
le problème le problème c'est des armes
si les missiles à courte portée que ou
alors d une arme anti missiles déployés
là aux portes de la russie c'est ça
qu'elle cherche finalement un résout le
problème que que les pays membres de
l'otan qui sont proches de ses
frontières ne seront pas utilisées pour
une agression éventuelles contre elle
c'est ça le coeur donc il faut que
l'europe sous une modalité à trouver
puisque l'europe finalement n'a pas de
force militaire elle n'est qu'une astres
un instrument diplomatique assez divisés
pas tout à fait unis entre elles mais il
faut qu'elles aient voix au chapitre
dans un règlement global qui prendra du
temps qui s'esquisse déjà puisque il ya
différentes par exemple el país dit
qu'il ya déjà des avancées que les
américains sont prêts à accorder
certaines garanties
il les lisait aussi a été très prudent
lors de l'entretien de la semaine
dernière en disant que oui monsieur
macron à écouter et il est prêt
également à étudier certaines garanties
que
l'occident c'est à dire autant et union
européenne pourrait apporter à à vladmir
poutine à la russie donc le dialogue est
là il commence il est très lent
évidemment je ne qualifierais pas et il
a une vitesse de sénateurs d'escargots
mais au moins il ya un dialogue qui est
compliqué encore une fois il a tellement
de canaux mais on peut on peut envisager
effectivement dans les jours à venir
s'il ya d'autres entretiens de passer à
une phase peut-être un peu plus
confidentiels tout ça ce sont des bruits
se sont un peu d un conte fumée et on va
arriver à une discussion entre experts
entrent en politique et qui va peut-être
se concentrer sur l'essentiel enfin en
tout cas c'est le voeu qu'on peut
formuler et je crois déceler quelques
jadis qui sembleraient montrer qu' on a
pris ce chemin avec prudence tout en
proclamant qu au cas où on prend dans
les sanctions dont il ya une espèce de
double jeu et il faudrait que le disons
la la joute verbale diminue pour laisser
plus de champ ou négociation très expert
et entre responsables merci beaucoup aux
jeunes berg ancien diplomate français
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france pour ce décryptage
en déplacement donc à tourcoing dans le
nord de la france emmanuel macron a
convié ce soir les 27 ministres de
l'intérieur européens pour parler
immigration le chef de l'état veut en
faire un sujet phare de la présidence
française de l'union européenne
il veut notamment s'attaquer aux
défaillances de l'espace schengen
écouter
schengen est un acquis européen et il a
permis de consolider cette europe à
laquelle nous tenons qui tout à la fois
une europe de la libre circulation des
personnes en toute sécurité en même
temps une europe qui protège ses
frontières extérieures
schengen a été conçu à une époque très
différente de celle que nous vivons
aujourd'hui avant la reprise du
terrorisme sur le sol européen et avant
la reprise très forte d'une migration
suite à la crise libyenne aux crises
successives depuis 2015 puis ces
derniers mois nous l'avons vu avant une
transformation qui est en cours celle
qui fait de l'immigration au fond une
une forme d'armes hybride de puissance
qui veulent nous déstabiliser pour
toutes ces raisons nous devons repenser
les équilibres de schengen d'abord en
faisant de schengen un espace qui est
piloté politiquement et donc ce que nous
souhaitons c'est au fond installé un
conseil schengen avec un coordonnateur
pour que de manière régulière les
ministres puissent prendre des décisions
avoir des rapports qu'ils soient faits
sur ses décisions prendre les textes
nécessaires piloter politiquement cet
espace et ses frontières communes au
fond comme nous le faisons pour un autre
de nos trésors commun qu'est l'euro et
pour en parler nous sommes avec claude
blanchemaison viens d'entendre à
emmanuel macron bonsoir comme
blanchemaison pardon envers l'entendent
emmanuel macron
dira en substance il est temps il est
venu le temps de changer cette pac
migratoire européen mais surtout
l'espace schengen nécessaire
effectivement aujourd'hui oui puisqu'on
a vu les échecs successifs et en 2015
avec les millions de réfugiés syriens et
puis jusqu'à aujourd'hui avec maintenant
les afghans et entre temps les réfugiés
qui venait du proche orient ou ou
d'afrique donc en effet schengen ne
donne plus les résultats escomptés et il
faut le changer dans la proposition qui
est faite par le président macron et une
proposition qu'on a déjà entendu un
certain nombre de fois sa consistance
est en fait à changer la gouvernance et
aux durées au lieu d'avoir une boîte
noire feu dans laquelle on prend des
décisions technocratiques dont personne
ne sait qui est responsable de quoi on
dit c'est le conseil des ministres dès
de l'intérieur des 27 états membres qui
sera responsable un peu comme on a fait
dès le départ pour la zone euro dans le
court la zone euro ce sont les mises et
finances qui se réunissent tous les mois
des mises finances des pays de la zone
euro et puis qui se réalise plus souvent
s'il ya des crises et qui prennent les
vraies décisions et bien là probablement
que nos partenaires seront assez
rapidement d'accord pour avoir cette
gouvernance beaucoup plus politique et
dans la main des états membres dans la
main des états membres et pas d'une
technocratie dont on ne connaît pas très
bien les tenants et les aboutissants
donc ça je pense que c'est un élément
dont on discute depuis un certain temps
et qui pourraient être retenues
d'ailleurs monsieur darmanin peut-être
devant son appel à plus ou moins inviter
ses collègues de la zone schengen à une
réunion le 3 mars à bruxelles je pense
qu'il a obtenu des réponses positives
sinon il on le dirait pas aujourd'hui
schengen c'est l'union européenne - cinq
états membres et +4 et spas extérieurs à
l'union européenne
la norvège l'islande qui est un peu loin
mais qui fait partie de schengen la
suisse et le petit liechtenstein donc
effectivement
ceci devrait pouvoir être fait avec une
première un premier passage à l'acte dès
le début du mois de mars et non le fait
que la commission européenne facilite le
principe de la non admission c'est une
bonne chose selon vous avons pas
l'ensemble du mécanisme trop complexe
alors ça ça touche uniquement la gestion
des frontières intérieures puisque ça
veut dire que si par exemple un migrant
qui était en allemagne passe en france
10 km en france après la frontière
allemande et il n'a pas encore intégré l
territoire français et par conséquent si
les prix il peut être renvoyé dans le
pays où ils étaient avant c'est à dire
l'allemagne
donc ceci implique en réalité que les
pays qui sont aux frontières de schengen
flux fasse pleinement leur travail et à
dire enregistre les les migrants qui
arrivent les enregistre complètement
concrets sans doute un système
biométrique unifié pour l'ensemble de la
zone de façon à ce que l'information
qu'il qu'ils inscrivent lors de
l'arrivée dans le pays de premier
accueil soit diffusé à tous les états
membres de schengen et tous les états
membres de schengen puisse tracer ces
migrants qui se déplace assez souvent
d'un pays à l'autre et qui demande dans
plusieurs pays l'asile alors en fait
schengen est mort de quoi il est mort de
la crise migratoire des crises
migratoires il est mort aussi
ducobu naturellement et et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement tout le
monde pense qu'il faut modifier le
système et avoir un système beaucoup
plus efficace enfin un président un
participant à une réunion européenne
aussi technique ça relève un petit peu
du du jamais vu pour en plus annoncé des
mesures assez ferme qui parle plutôt à
la droite selon je n'ai pas avant tout
politique à quelques mois de la
présidentielle
heureusement il n'y avait pas d'
ministre britannique puisqu'il en est
sans parti s'il y avait eu à ministre
britannique probablement il se serait
absenté
oui le remak manifesté sa mauvaise
humeur au moment de la conférence du
président français à cet ensemble des
ministres d'aidé de l'intérieur des
états membres de l'union européenne mais
je pense que les ministres des états
membres étaient d'abord prévenu donc je
savais à quoi ils s'attendaient et on
leur avait dit qu'ils pourraient
discuter avec le président et ça peut
être pour eux ça avait un intérêt de
discuter peut directement avec le le
président de la république pour pouvoir
ramener chez eux des informations plus
précises et puis continue entre à leurs
travaux demain avec monsieur darmana de
toute manière alors sur l'aspect
présidentielle et sur l'aspect campagne
électorale bon bien sûr le président de
la république affiche ses convictions et
comme tout le monde veut contrôler les
frontières d'ailleurs c'est un des
effets de la crise sanitaire et des
crises précédentes les attentats aussi
qui ont fait que les frontières
nationales ont été ressuscités et que
l'on le fond nouveau système géré par la
réunion des ministres des divisions
intérieures des 27 états membres en
effet fort à une plus grande part aux
états membres qu'à la commission ou
qu'au système un peu un peu abstrait de
schengen merci beaucoup claudin
blanchemaison pour ce décryptage
et dans le reste de l'actualité
l'insécurité alimentaire en forte hausse
dans 20 pays et régions du monde selon
un récent rapport de l'onu en cause
principalement la fuite des populations
et l'abandon de leurs terres agricoles
ces deux cas au nigeria où les conflits
entre éleveurs nomades et agriculteurs
font rage un sujet signé grâce die à
battre la paille pour en récolter le
grain c'est le travail harassant
d'ibrahim et sa famille cultivateurs de
riz un travail qui lui permettait de
mettre sa famille à l'abri de la faim
juste avant la taille de sa ferme il ya
maintenant trois ans depuis que les
fulani sont venus attaquer notre village
détruire nos terres agricoles et mettre
le feu à nos récoltes nous n'avons plus
d'argent pour cultiver comme avant
regardez mes terres il y a tellement de
mauvaises herbes personne ne peut
m'aider à les contrôler et je n'ai pas
d'argent pour acheter des produits
chimiques pour que la récolte soit bonne
avant j'avais l'habitude de récolter 10
sacs de riz de 120 kg mais cette année
je ne peux même pas voir jusqu'à trois
sacs parce que je n'ai pas de gens pour
m'aider et pas d'argent pour acheter des
produits chimiques le cas d'ibrahim
illustre le conflit entre éleveurs
fulani et agriculteurs sédentaires qui
sévit dans l'état de benue et certaines
régions du nord du nigeria une guerre de
l'eau à laquelle s'ajoutent
l'insurrection des extrémistes
islamistes conflit qui a fait plus de
3600 morts entre 2016 et 2018 selon un
rapport d'amnesty international les
autorités locales craignent des
conséquences sur tout le pays
les plus pauvres quand vous laisser ces
gens dont la plupart produisent environ
34% il y a un défi
parce que même ceux qui ont tenté de
retourner dans leurs fermes ont été
tuées par ces bergers foulani et se sont
enfuis
ce qui a suscité la peur chez beaucoup
de gens des populations qui ne veulent
plus retourner sur leurs terres dans une
région où plus de 70% de la population
travaille dans le secteur agricole riz
l'igname ou encore soja l'état de benue
avait même le titre de pagny alimentaire
de la nation passent aux violences
nombreux sont ceux qui ont dû partir et
se réfugier dans des camps comme tonga
pour nourrir sa famille cette
agricultrice a dû se résigner
il n'y a pas de nourriture ici je dois
travailler pour d'autres personnes en
tant qu'ouvrière pour que moi mes
enfants et mon mari puisse y ont mangé
depuis que nous avons été envoyés ici il
est très difficile de vivre sans
nourriture
le repas que je prépare et pour 10
personnes et c'est notre premier repas
de la journée
bye bye
nous continuons à prier pour avoir du
travail demain afin d'avoir plus
d'argent pour manger
insécurité alimentaire mais aussi
menaces économiques malgré sa position
de leader dans la production de pétrole
brut d'afrique les finances du nigeria
sont dépendantes de l'agriculture elles
constituent 30% du produit intérieur
brut du pays selon le rapport du
programme alimentaire mondial de l'onu
l'afrique serait le continent le plus
touché par l'insécurité alimentaire
ailleurs dans le monde la birmanie et
l'afghanistan sont eux aussi concernés
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
à nos parleront du pouvoir d'achat dans
notre rubrique qu'en pensent les
français nous irons à la rencontre d'un
boulanger son équipe aujourd'hui n'ont
plus le choix pour survivre ils ont mis
à jour monter le prix de leur baguette
le pouvoir d'achat est il désormais
l'inquiétude numéro un des français on
en débat dans quelques ce titre
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui ai des gants dit il
n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft
[Musique]
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu livrant
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pj jones étaient
des valeurs de droite c'était des gens
qui travaillent c'est les gens qui
avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose alors jean francky
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct il y a
quand même la liberté je vous remercie
de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
l'afrique la nouvelle crypte hollande on
a l'impression d'assister un phénomène
de mode qui est amenée à durer
véritablement sur le continent nous
sommes juste entré dans une nouvelle ère
du système financier et la population
africaine c'est un milliard d'habitants
c'est ça à la valeur de nos crypto
monnaie
notre objectif c'est d'avoir de plus en
plus de partenaires qui acceptent notre
crypto comme moyen de paiement qu'en ce
cas ci nous parce que l'argent liquide
perd de la valeur beaucoup de pays en
afrique ont interdit la crypto est ce
que vous répondez à cela d'une canette
on ne peut pas dire on va interdire la
crypto tout temps qu'il ya internet il y
aura des crypto
[Musique]
faux
je
[Musique]
l'afrique la nouvelle crypte hollande on
a l'impression d'assister un phénomène
de mode qui est amenée à durer
véritablement sur le continent nous
sommes juste entré dans une nouvelle ère
du système financier et la population
africaine c'est un milliard d'habitants
c'est ça à la valeur de nos crypto
monnaie
notre objectif c'est d'avoir de plus en
plus de partenaires qui acceptent notre
crypto comme moyen de paiement qu'en ce
crash si nous parce que l'argent liquide
perd de la valeur beaucoup de pays en
afrique on t'interdit
la crypto est ce que vous répondez à
cela du canada on ne peut pas dire on va
interdire la crypto tout temps qu'il ya
internet il y aura des crypto
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
d
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire à la hausse des prix des
matières premières le prix du beurre
s'est envolé de 33% sur les trois
derniers mois dans notre rubrique en
pensent les français nous irons à la
rencontre ce soir un boulanger son
équipe qui souffrent eux aussi de cette
augmentation
aujourd'hui n'ont plus le choix pour
survivre ils envisagent d'augmenter le
prix de leur baguette est pour vous le
pouvoir d'achat est il désormais
l'inquiétude première on attend vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme daté
france
et l'inflation va donc de nouveau record
+ 5% dans la zone euro en janvier
largement au dessus des prévisions de la
bce en décembre les prix avaient déjà
progressé de 5% en raison de la hausse
des prix de l'énergie gaz électricité en
tête du jamais vu depuis 25 ans pour les
pays qui ont adopté la monnaie unique
des pays des prix qui augmentent tous
azimuts pas très bon forcément quand on
est un présent d'un président qui
s'apprête à se lancer en campagne on en
parle tout de suite avec notre
éditorialiste rt france eric revel
elik merci d'être avec nous on le voir
les français qui souffrent on va en
parler longuement tout à l'heure avec le
témoignage d'un boulanger suivi d'un
petit débat les français pris à la gorge
pour payer leurs factures on a toujours
dit que emmanuel macron était le
président du pouvoir d'achat en tout cas
lui s'en défend il ya quelques chiffres
qui vont dans le même sens mais tout de
même contestations sur sur ce bilan en
tout cas sur le ressenti des français
sur le terrain alors j'ai pas si on a
dit que emmanuel macron était le
président du pouvoir d'achat en tout cas
françois hollande lui le dit a dit lui
que c'était le président des riches
surtout vous souvenez sans doute de
cette phrase qui avait fait beaucoup
parler ce qui est incontestable c'est
que dans toutes les enquêtes d'opinion
qui sortent à quelque 68 jours de cette
élection présidentielle le thème du
pouvoir d'achat c'est le thème numéro un
des français devant la sécurité ou
devant la question d'ailleurs de
l'immigration donc c'est un thème
évidemment très important parce que le
pays depuis la crise sanitaire même si
le quoi qu'il en coûte à fait du bien
avec le chômage partiel payés par l'état
le pays est presque en train de tomber
dans une sorte de crise sociale il ya
des crises communautaire il ya une crise
sociale profonde dont vous avez une
question de pouvoir d'achat en france
qui récurrente des salaires qui n'ont
pas suffisamment augmenté parce que les
entreprises pendant cette crise
sanitaire qui était une crise économique
ont évidemment ralenti d'augmentation
des salaires et vous avez par dessus
tout ça vous venez de lire une inflation
qui gagnent beaucoup de terrain quand
vous avez des salaires qui n'augmentent
pas et une inflation qui rogne le
pouvoir d'achat eh bien vous avez des
situations sociales notamment pour les
plus modestes qui deviennent extrêmement
préoccupante et quand on regarde juste
un chiffre 1 les études je pense à
l'institut des des politiques publiques
qui a publié cette étude en fait vous
rendez compte que même si on peut
opposer une étude à une étude mais bon
on est content que sous emmanuel macron
sont plutôt les plus riches qui ont
accru leur pouvoir d'achat alors que les
plus modestes et les plus pauvres au
contraire ont vu leur pouvoir d'achat
rogné donc ça c'est une étude qui le
montrent et évidemment le présent de la
république qui va être candidat qui va
rentrer dans cette élection il va devoir
avec son nouveau projet politique
économique assurer les français pour
qu'il le réalise qu'il fera quelque
chose mais est il encore crédible pour
le pouls leur pouvoir d'achat parce que
le pouvoir d'achat ces notions un peu un
peu irréel qui est pas forcément
concrètes mais c'est très concrètement
comment vous nourrissez votre famille
comment vous payer votre loyer comment
vous payer vos factures d'énergie qui
n'ont fait qu'augmenter en france
notamment alors il ya pas qu emmanuel
macron qui n'a d'ailleurs toujours pas
déclaré sa candidature évidemment il ya
les autres on les voit la padère tous
les jours faire
les organes euros
les hommes politiques justement de se
payer ce qu'ils ont pris la mesure de la
pauvreté qui est en train de s'installer
que vous nous avez décrite oui quand
vous regardez les programmes des
principaux candidats de gauche et de
droite en france évidemment il ya des
mesures salariales qui sont proposés ci
voulait il ya deux types de mesures que
vous soyez un candidat de gauche vous
soyez un candidat de droite quand vous
êtes de gauche vous essayez d'avoir
comme marqueur l'augmentation du smic le
salaire minimum parce que par définition
votre électorat est plutôt dans cette
catégorie là même si on peut être riche
et voter à gauche donc la gauche est
plutôt augmentation du smic vous avez
des gens aujourd'hui il est à 1260 euros
il ya des gens jean luc mélenchon anne
hidalgo qui propulse mika 1400 à 1500
euros ça c'est pour la vision de gauche
d'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
notamment des catégories sociales les
plus modestes à droite c'est une autre
approche à droite on appris aussi
évidemment conscience du problème du
pouvoir d'achat mais à droite on ne
parle pas forcément d'augmentation du
smic on parle de d'allègement des
charges et des cotisations ce qui
intéresse par exemple valérie pécresse
dans son programme c'est d'alléger les
charges sur la feuille de paye pour que
le salaire net augmente mais évidemment
si vous alléger les charges et moins de
recettes pour l'état et l'état qui est
déjà dans une situation compliquée de
1900 milliards d'euros de dette voilà
cette question est prise aussi c'était
ma prochaine question parce que toutes
ces mesures qu'elle propose évidemment
joyeusement nos candidats à la
présidentielle eh bien comment on les
finance qu'on sait pas la compétitive
compétitivité qui en prend un coup sur
l'augmentation du smic et bien
effectivement c'est le financement qui
pose question vous avez bien sûr alors
bon lait les candidats ont chiffré un
peu la louche comme mon dealer leur
programme mais c'est vrai que ce sont
des dizaines de milliards d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires g ou prendre un
autre exemple plus que la crise de
l'énergie est très forte
en france le prix de l'essence s'envole
le prix du gasoil vous avez par exemple
parler de l'open qui dit je vais mettre
une tva à 5,5 sur tous les produits
énergétiques aujourd'hui je crois que
sur l'une des sens elle est à 16% alors
vous dites magnifique sauf que quand
vous passez de 16% à 5 5 pour l'état ce
sont des milliards et des milliards de
recettes en moins qui ne rendent pas et
quand vous savez que la tva c'est le
premier impôt en france est un vrai
sujet est ce que maintenant les français
vont élire ou réélire leur nouveau
président de la république en leur
nouvelle présidente de la république sur
un programme sur un projet ça c'est une
question centrale parce que les projets
y en a toujours eu les mesures avancées
pour appâter le vote est toujours été
extrêmement ronflante et puis derrière
il y avait forcément une très grosse
désillusion parce que le financement il
n'est pas du tout assurée et parfois
même je vais vous dire certains
candidats mettre un peu de côté le coût
de leurs mesures ce qui les intéresse le
plus c'est le symbole que représente
cette mesure pour l'électorat politique
qu'il vise haut pour le reste c'est un
peu après moi le déluge on suivra
également avec attention pendant le
reste de cette campagne merci à vous et
eric revel éditorialistes rt france et
partant justement sur le terrain présent
la hausse des prix concrètement comment
elle se répercute et qu'en pensent les
français nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de sébastien à hertz et les
boulangers et paris est depuis plusieurs
mois ses factures flamber marche se
réduisent à vue d'oeil il doit se
résoudre à augmenter ses prix reportage
katia technique et sa liste
je suis dans le xviiie arrondissement de
paris devant la boulangerie au levain
d'antan pour rencontrer celle qui comme
tous les boulangers en ce moment on
connaît des problèmes a fortiori si
aussi bonjour savoir que si vous avez
mais l'augmentation du prix des matières
premières est quand même assez important
et voulait dire farine varient
les eaux les céréales tout augmente
tourmente et du coup on va être obligé à
fortiori d'augmenter nos prix chose
qu'on s'était refusé à faire jusqu'à
maintenant on va plus répercuter les
prix sur la viennoiserie là où il ya
beaucoup de beurre là où il ya beaucoup
de travail et sur le prix des pains
spéciaux est ce que vous avez peur que
des clients puissent vous boudez venir -
parce que de ça va c'est de plus en plus
cher alors je pense que c'est pas nous
bouder ils vont pas nous bouder ils vont
ils subissent comme nous l'augmentation
de tous donc un moment donné il va
falloir qu'ils fassent des choix et
est-ce que de ce fait vous perdez du
chiffre d'affaires oui complètement là
on a eu sur sur le mois de décembre est
le mois de janvier qui sont normalement
des mois qui permettent de renflouer un
peu les caisses et d'avoir de la
trésorerie
on a eu une perte de chiffre d'affaires
d'un peu plus de 10% donc si vous voulez
m'accompagner dans le fournil on va
parler un peu de tout ça on sera mis au
chaud
[Musique]
je pense que ça va vous déprime
les matières premières qu on peut voir
ici elles ont augmenté en quelle
proportion la farine elle a augmenté
en proportion de plus ou moins 10% le
beurre il a augmenté de presque 40% il
ya plusieurs raisons à ça je pense
l'augmentation du prix du pétrole ou
tout ce qui est transporter les
spéculations liées à la farine liés au
blé mais là c'est tout d'un coup on fait
tous qui augmente d'un coup c'est nos
matières premières c'est nos matières
avec laquelle lesquels on travaille tous
les jours on ne peut même pas s'en
passer donc on peut même pas les
remplacer nous il a fallu qu'on s'adapte
tout le temps et pour autant ben on est
un petit peu les oubliés
pour les gens qui ont déjà du mal à
payer le loyer à finir à finir le mois
c'est vrai qu'une augmentation d'une
baguette qui est un produit de base
c'est vraiment quelque chose de
compliqué et pour les patrons aussi pour
pour garder leurs employés avec tous les
prix qui augmentent mais du coup ça fait
une tension sur les salaires qui est qui
est compliqué à tenir aussi pauvre je
suis arrivé à un seuil d'inquiétude dont
du du fait que 20 tous les mois là on
est en train de réfléchir à comment
ne pas perdre trop d'argent et gagner un
petit peu pour
pour être tranquille pour pouvoir payer
nos salariés pour pouvoir payer nos
fournisseurs pour pouvoir payer les
charges pour pouvoir payer nos emprunts
et puis après ben pouvoir se payer soi
même
aujourd'hui vous avez dû augmenter mais
très peu de produits vous avez dû le
faire alors la baguette vous ne
toucherez pas on verra ça dans quelques
mois est ce qu'elle est déjà augmenté
ces dernières années alors nous on l'a
augmentée il ya quelques années on est
resté à 1 euro 20 et on espère y rester
malheureusement je crois que si on doit
l'augmenter ben l'augmentera que pensez
vous de cette concurrence des grandes
surfaces avec leur fameuse baguette à 29
centimes d'euros ça pour moi c'est
inadmissible c'est inadmissible de
pouvoir se dire qu'un agriculteur un
céréalier
derrière cette vague est à 29 centimes
et payés au juste prix qu'un meunier est
payé au juste prix que le transporteur
est payé au juste prix et que le
boulanger derrière et payés au juste
prix 29 centimes si ça marche pas donc
c'est clairement une sorte de diversion
marketing en fait pour attirer le client
oui c'est pour attirer le client certes
mais derrière les gens se posent la
question mais pourquoi vous votre
baguette elle est à 1 euro 20 ben on
n'est pas dans la même catégorie en fait
alors c'est à bloquer deux courriers du
besoin maintenant pour survivre faut que
votre activité se maintienne que les
prix cesse d'augmenter comme comme ils
sont en train d'augmenter que ça se
stabilise un petit peu on aurait besoin
d'un soutien de l'état on aura besoin
d'eux que tout fonctionne comme avant
que le restaurant fonctionne que les
français re consomme que les français
aient confiance en nous et qui que le
gouvernement et vit à arrête de nous de
nous taxer
constamment de toutes ces augmentations
de prix toutes ses deux toutous qui
augmente à un moment donné ça va mettre
en péril notre savoir faire alors
comment ne pas perdre trop d'argent pour
pouvoir se verser un salaire après avoir
payé toutes ces charges c'est la
difficile équation à laquelle tente de
répondre chaque jour commerçants et
artisans le pouvoir d'achat est la
principale préoccupation des français
les candidats à la présidentielle ont
ils bien compris c'est l'objet de notre
face à face
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir
vincent chauvet maire modem d'hôtes un
bon soir vincent chauvet merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés guillaume roux
bokashi porte parole de fabien roussel
candidat du parti communiste donc à la
présidentielle merci à vous d'être là
également on est les oubliés nous dit
sébastien ayats tout comment tout
augmente prix de l'énergie prix des
matières premières et notre boulanger
qui réclament de juste pouvoir vivre de
son travail en étant payés au juste prix
il a raison comme dirait certaine c'est
une colère scène guillaume robot gâchis
bien sûr c'est une colle ersonne parce
que la france qui est une grande
puissance mondiale est en train de
devenir un pays de bas salaires et ça ne
peut pas continuer comme ça c'est un
problème pour les gens qui vit avec ses
bas salaires c'est un problème pour
l'économie générale du pays puis c'est
un problème de justice sociale de ce
point de vue oui c'est un problème et
nous nous demandons une augmentation
forte de la rémunération et notamment du
chimique avec une augmentation qui
l'amènerait à 1500 euros net parce que
il faut pouvoir vivre dignement de son
travail
vincent chauvet même constat comment
répondre à la priorité de sébastien qui
est celle évidemment de nombreux
français c'est-à-dire faire en sorte que
les prix déjà n'augmente plus
bon effectivement où on voit très bien
chez ce boulanger le constat est très
clair il est partagé pas partout en
france
qu' il ya une pression sur les matières
premières il ya une pression sur les
salariés il faut aussi payer dans un
contexte de pénurie sur un marché
travail de baisse du chômage il faut le
dire eh bien il faut payer de plus en
plus ses salariés pour qu'il reste et
pour avoir des bons salariés motivés et
on voit pour ce petit patron que
finalement le dernier as payé quand il a
payé ses empreintes ses charges ses
salariés ses matières premières ses
fournisseurs c'est lui et donc
effectivement là il y a il ya un souci
quand il a été très bien montré en
reportage on a à la fois une hausse
importante des prix de l'énergie et puis
pour les salariés mais aussi pour les
commerçants une hausse importante des
prix de l'immobilier donc on peut agir
sur plusieurs leviers l énergie les prix
de l'immobilier on peut agir sur la
fiscalité mais typiquement pour ce petit
boulanger une hausse du smic n'aurait
strictement aucun effet et ça ne devrait
pas à regagner du chiffre d'affaires on
va regagner des clients et des marges
oui alesi elle hésite entre un petit mot
d'être un petit bol j'ai parlé du smic
parce que c'est un élément qui dans la
main du pouvoir public après on
réfléchit nous voulons aller vers une
augmentation générale des salaires et la
pousser dans son stade et l'état des
instruments s'il souhaite le faire mais
ne disons pas que se nourrir de bonnes
façons ça n'a aucun rapport avec avec le
pouvoir d'achat c'est pas vrai comment
dire des boulangers de qualité il offre
des produits que n'offrent pas toujours
les supermarchés si on veut avoir du bon
père et donc c'est pas vrai que de
considérer que d'augmenter le niveau des
salaires dans la population générale non
mais pas de soutenir le nombre de
clients qui existent auprès de boulanger
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse se poser
les choses comme ça
en tout cas je voulais vous proposer une
première réaction de téléspectateurs à
la question de savoir si le pouvoir
d'achat et bien c'est la priorité numéro
un des français alex on dit et bien vu
le prix de l'essence et l'électricité
difficile d'avoir d'autres priorités
aujourd'hui guillaume moreau beau gâchis
finalement c'est une chance ou un piège
pour emmanuel macron cette priorité 1 du
pouvoir d'achat alors qu'on sait que son
bilan sécuritaire est souvent critiquée
en gros finalement est-ce que ça peut
l'aider manuel maquereau ou au contraire
lui lui desservir eu égard à son bilan
sur cette question écoutez évidemment si
on regarde les choses vu de loin on
pourrait penser que ça peut l'aider et
il s'appuie sur des chiffres de
dévolution d'en moyenne du pouvoir
d'achat et donc quand le fc eu par
exemple indique que le pouvoir d'achat
en moyenne des français a beaucoup
augmenté mais quand on regarde le ce que
dilma rousseff ses yeux par exemple pour
le début du quinquennat qu'est ce qu'il
dit il dit que un quart de
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat gagné
par l'ensemble des français est allé aux
5 % des ménages les plus aisés donc
nominé le maquereau n'a pas un bon bilan
quand on regarde vraiment ce qu'est
l'évolution du pouvoir d'achat de
l'ensemble des français et il a mené une
politique de président des riches
vincent chauvet parce que c'est vrai que
l aie aie il ya une vraie polémique un
sûre en tout cas une confusion l'insee 1
tiens on va voir d'ailleurs les chiffres
par exemple fait polémique car parce que
la majorité comme unique allègrement sur
les chiffres de l'insee présente
emmanuel macron comme le président du
pouvoir d'achat regardez d'ailleurs ce
tweet avant nous fait réagir du député
la reine gilles legendre
en 2021 près de 4 millions de nos
concitoyens ont bénéficié de la prime
acron versée par les entreprises s'en
charger sans impôt sur la base du
volontariat
les salariés ont touché en moyenne 5 106
euros le président du pouvoir d'achat
c'est emmanuel macron voilà alors ça
c'est ce que nous dit le député l'as
raismes et soutenu un petit peu par les
chiffres de l'insee sauf que le pouvoir
d'achat c'est un peu comme la météo a
raillé à la température en chiffres il
ya le ressenti sur le terrain ça vous en
avez quand même conscience parce que le
boulanger je pense qu'il est pas
vraiment d'accord avec jean legendre
oui oui absolument il y a le les
chiffres de l'insee et puis le le
ressenti notamment parce qu'il ya aussi
une différence entre le pouvoir d'achat
et puis finalement le le pouvoir d'achat
arbitrable quand on a un certain nombre
de dépenses contraintes et les prix de
l'énergie sont des dépenses contraintes
le plein pour aller travailler c'est une
dépense contrainte et qu'on voit plus
facilement les chiffres lumineux sur la
station service en bas de chez soi que à
des augmentations de 1 ou 2 % de
dépenses arbitrable en fin de mois ce
que dit gilles legendre est très vrai et
nous au modem on veut aussi poussé ce
vrai sujet de pouvoir d'achat qui est un
vrai sujet bien plus important je pense
dans la tête des français et pour le
pays que de pseudo polémique sur
l'immigration ou la sécurité mais sur le
pouvoir d'achat effectivement ce qui a
été fait est ce que nous souhaiterions
pérenniser c'est la prime macro pourquoi
parce que c'est extrêmement simple et
aussi parce que ce n'est pas de la
démagogie c'est pas des promesses en
l'air c'est pas des promesses de gascon
roux c'est une négociation entre patrons
et salariés quand une entreprise fait
des bénéfices et bien en fin d'année
elle peut distribuer un deux voire trois
smic et de manière extrêmement simple
soit en direct soit sur des plans
d'épargné des parts salariales le
général de gaulle ne disait pas autre
amant et donc avec emmanuel macron à la
suite d'ailleurs de la crise des jeunes
qui aussi partie sur le pouvoir d'achat
il faut s'en souvenir et bien cette
prime macron est un vrai succès est là
prêt a permis un meilleur partage de des
richesses et notamment un meilleur
partage des marges et des bénéfices des
entreprises au cours des dernières
années ça a été créé un peu comme ça et
finalement c'est très simple ça marche
bien et nous on propose sur le
quinquennat prochain si la majorité
présentielle présent la république est
réélu de le pérenniser parce qu'il faut
à la fois la faire confiance aux
entreprises aux salariés et aux
négociations salariales mais aussi à des
sportifs simple parce que aujourd'hui
l'actionnariat salarié la participation
ça peut être compliqué la prima kron
c'est simple et ça marche et bien un
nouveau gâchis il a pris macarons ça
marchera pas que ça on va voir pendant
que vous vous exprimez les autres
mesures mettront notamment sur l'énergie
le chèque de 100 euros sur l'énergie la
taxe d'habitation
il ya eu quelques mesures que vente
allègrement évidemment la majorité
qu'est ce que vous répondez
c'est qu'un début c'est énorme un début
pas mal
non non mais j'y mairie qu'il devrait
mettre pour dans les gains de pouvoir
d'achat ils devraient mettre la
suppression de l'impôt sur la fortune et
toutes les mesures énorme qui ont privé
l'état de monsieur d'argent de manière
considérable pour faire des cadeaux aux
plus riches alors ceux du gain de
pouvoir d'achat très bien mais pour les
très très riches ça ça compte beaucoup
plus que les petites pièces est envoyé
et c'est pas sa demande nous ne
demandons pas la charité des primes des
petites des petites miettes comme ça on
demande une augmentation des salaires de
pouvoir vivre dignement de son travail
et si on parle de la fonction publique
puisque on a parlé du secteur privé
faudrait quand même rappeler qu'avec
l'inflation qui arrive le gel du point
d'indicé qui existe depuis bientôt 15
ans il est insupportable
écoutez moi je vous parlais que j'avais
mon exemple d'enseignant je suis
enseignant on a une prime blanc coeur de
35 euros par mois 35 euros par mois ça
suffit mais j'ai aucune envie d'avoir
une prime blanc 4 5 euros par mois ça
suffit donc non il faut être très clair
sur la question des salariés du privé il
ya besoin d'augmenter les salaires
regardez ce qui se passe en allemagne on
parle d'augmenter le smic de 20% il faut
augmenter le smic qui font augmenter le
smic a augmenté l'ensemble des salaires
il faut garantir des pensions qu'ils ne
soient pas au-dessous de 1200 euros
grâce notamment notre député andré
chassaigne il ya eu des mesures
intéressant pour des prises en direction
des retraites agricoles il faut
continuer il faut aller plus loin mais
là ne parlons pas de cette
généralisation de ce système de primes
de petites pièces de charité c'est pas
ça le sujet le sujet c'est est ce que
dans notre pays on peut vivre dignement
de son travail vincent chauvet je vais
vous montrer un sondage ifop lac qui
montrent effectivement les trois
catégories qui ont le moins bénéficié
des mesures appliquées durant ce
quinquennat vous le voyez en bas de non
c'est pas ce chiffre mais en bas de
tableau les classes moyennes on va le
voir peut-être les habitants des
communes rurales et les retraités le
président est quand même passé à côté
depuis cinq ans et ça rejoint ce que
vient de nous dire guillaume roux beau
gâchis enfin c'est vrai que voilà 35 ans
de pouvoir de 35 euros pouvoir d'achat
pour les profs sais c'est pas c'est pas
beaucoup quand même il faut changer tout
le système
oui alors d'une part effectivement il y
avait une anomalie dans notre système
social c'est que le niveau de vie moyen
des retraités était supérieur à celui
des actifs donc j'ai pas qu'il faille
baisser le niveau de vie des retraités
mais il ya eu une politique pendant ce
quinquennat effectivement de redonner du
pouvoir d'achat aux actifs et ça a
marché après je pense que tous les
candidats sont d'accord notamment dans
une période de croissance et de retour
de la hausse des prix de l'énergie
l'inflation sous jacente qu'il faille
augmenter les salaires bon ça c'est
évident en revanche les là où les
programmes vont se comparer c'est sur
comment nous on pense qu'augmenter le
smic c'est une promesse qui coûte pas
grand chose à l'état qui repose sur les
patrons dans des entreprises qui dans
certains secteurs on démarche qui sont
tendues avec un et serait décrit des
salaires et des bas salaires au niveau
du smic avec des gens qui parfois ont
attendu dix ou quinze ans pour sortir du
smic est aujourd'hui qui pourrait se
retrouver si cette mesure est expliqué
et appliqué de nouveau au niveau du
salaire minimum c'est pas forcément
souhaitable et comme je le dis il y à
des mesures qui sont pas du tout de
l'aumône et avoir alors quand on est à
fonctionner on s'en rend peut être pas
compte mais quand on travaille dans le
privé d'avoir une prime défiscaliser de
1 ou 2 mois de salaire à la fin de
l'année quand l'entreprise a bien bossé
et que collectivement da dégager de la
marge ça compte et sur le journaliste
des fonctionnaires je pense qu'il faut
qu'il y ait en effet en effet une
réflexion ça fait trop longtemps que le
les le point d'indicé est gelé on va pas
dire que les salaires des fonctionnaires
seront gelés puisque il ya une
progression mécanique année après année
donc ne faisons pas croire que les les
fonctionnaires non plus n'est pas eu des
revalorisations effectivement le point
lundi et est quand même gelé et le
niveau de vie des fonctionnaires a
évolué moins vite que l'inflation avec
pour certaines catégories une perte de
pouvoir d'achat on voit notamment à des
catégories de fonctionnaires qui sont
plus du tout attractif ou moins
attractifs les profs ya eu un débat et
anne hidalgo a raison je pense de dire
qu'il fallait augmenter le salaire des
profs mais nous aussi dans la fonction
publique territoriale dans les mairies
dans les communes quand on veut
embaucher du personnel et que dans le
privé on gagne pain ou 30% plus cher ça
devient compliqué et donc ça coûte ça va
coûter aux finances publiques c'est une
réflexion globale qu'il faut avoir mais
il n'est pas en tout cas moi quand je
reçois les syndicats sur ces
revendications il n'est pas inconcevable
de le faire je note néanmoins qu'on
vient de passer le parti communiste
serait pas très content mais on vient de
passer de nouveau de retour aux 35
heures ont travaillé trente deux heures
et demie dans un certain nombre de
communes on est passé de nouveaux 35
heures dans la fonction publique d'état
on a fait passer un nouveau régime
indemnitaire donc il ya eu même sur
l'amour et que même avec un gel du quiz
indice un regain de pouvoir d'achat en
tout cas c'est l'une des mesures phare
du de fabien roussel pour ce pouvoir
d'achat l'augmentation du smic 1 voyez
ces candidats de gauche fabien roussel a
va jusqu'à augmenter le smic à 1800
euros
gohourou beau gâchis ça coûterait 53
milliards tout de même aux entreprises
ans selon l'observatoire est ce que
c'est la question j'imagine qu'on vous
pose souvent mais ce que vous avez pas
peur parti communiste de freiner la
compétitivité tout de même des
entreprises
il ya deux choses d'abord si on veut
toujours aller plus bas dans la
rémunération des gens on peut rappeler
peut-être le niveau du smic en romani et
500 euros aussi l'idée c'est toujours
attention si vous augmentez les salaires
tout le monde va partir en roumanie il
va leur payer comme les gens combien
donc ils ne partent pas en roumanie
c'est un argument qui va nous amener
jusqu'à la misère non je ne pense pas
qu'il faille trop tiré sain de corps de
la par ailleurs pour il faut aussi
affronter plusieurs questions et à la
question des charges et notamment des
charges liées aux frais bancaires aux
frais d'assurance aux frais
d'électricité et dont nous avons une
politique ambitieuse en la matière nous
pensons qu'il faut développer un pôle
public de l'assurance un pôle public
bancaire en nationalisant parce que
c'est ça qu'il faudra bien faire la
société générale on est suffisant des
banques la bnp en nationalisant axa par
exemple dont il faut baisser ces charges
la importantes qui sont là bas oui la
louche et évidemment vous aimez
privatiser je comprends vous fassiez
avec des grands regard on les privatiser
à peu près tous comprend bien maintenant
on peut avoir une ambition pour notre
pays et je pense est important donc
cette question là il ya aussi évidemment
aller chez des mesures à prendre en
matière d'électricité nous nous pensons
qu effectivement il faut reprendre la
main sur le contrôle du prix de
l'électricité et avoir une baisse
significative en la matière une baisse
significative également du côté de
l'essence parce que on sait très bien
que sont les taxes qui représentent
l'essentiel du coût payé à la pompe
quand on éteint quand on va chercher de
l'essence donc de ce côté là évidemment
il ya aussi la mise en place d'une taxe
flottante nous disons qu'il faut mettre
ça en place rapidement donc oui je suis
on est bien conscient que pour les
entreprises c'est pas facile de s'en
sortir mais justement nous pensons et
nous avons des propositions en la
matière merci en tout cas à tous les
deux vincent chauvet
robot gâchis d'avoir accepté ce face à
face et c'est la fin de cette émission
rendez vous demain pour un nouveau
numéro d'ici là n'oubliez pas de réagir
de commenter et poser vos questions sur
le télégramme verte et france
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple c'était
une volonté collective vous le savez
pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative on sent du politique il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain temps